[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien schönen guten Abend
ihnen allen mit mir im Studio für den
Sport ist wieder Katja streso und auch
von mir einen schönen guten Abend ja was
ist wichtig was wird wichtig hier ist
unsere Übersicht
Juniper for Verstaatlichung wenn der
Bund den angeschlagenen gasimporteur
übernimmt wackelt auch die umstrittene
gasumlage
Reaktion auf ukrainische Erfolge moskau
will in den besetzten Regionen schon ab
Freitag über einen Beitritt zu Russland
abstimmen lassen
rekordanstieg bei Erzeugerpreisen auch
diese Verteuerung bekommen wohl bald die
Verbraucher zu spüren
[Musik]
was wurde kritisiert und geschimpft über
die geplante gasumlage jetzt wird
bekannt dass der schwer angeschlagene
Düsseldorfer Gaskonzern Juniper der
davon am meisten profitiert hätte
verstaatlicht werden soll und nun steht
die gasumlage die ab Oktober sämtliche
Gasverbraucher getroffen hätte doch auf
dem Prüfstand fraglich ob sie überhaupt
noch kommt mehr zur Entwicklung und
Kurskorrektur von Patricia Wiedemeyer
es war ein ständiges Hin und Her heute
laufend neue Meldungen und Dementis aus
dem Wirtschaftsministerium jedoch nichts
Konkretes zur gasumlage bestätigt wurde
nur dass das Ministerium Finanz
verfassungsrechtliche Zweifel hat dies
müsse jetzt das Finanzministerium prüfen
sollte sich die Rechtsnatur der
Unternehmen ändern die von dieser Umlage
profitieren dann ist es natürlich so
dass man auch die Rechtsnatur der Umlage
noch einmal bewerten muss im Klartext
geht es darum dass wohl die finanzielle
Not des gasimporteurs uniper so groß ist
dass eine Verstaatlichung anscheinend
kurz bevorsteht ob in einem solchen Fall
die gasumlage die ja ebenfalls die
gasimporteure Stützen würde noch
rechtlich zulässig ist noch nötig ist
fraglich die SPD jedenfalls will selber
die gasumlage rechtlich prüfen würde
einer Verstaatlichung von Juniper aber
zustimmen wenn jetzt andere auch zu
dieser Überzeugung kommen sollten dass
das der richtige Weg ist werden wir das
unterstützen sollte die gasumlage nicht
Nachkommen dann fordert der
Koalitionspartner FDP Alternativen eine
gasumlage die so gemacht ist dass sie
die Preise senkt und dass sie vernünftig
funktioniert ist gut wenn das nicht der
Fall ist da muss man aber ein anderes
Instrument finden was nicht ausreichen
wird ist nichts zu tun die Union spricht
von schlampiger Planung fordert erneut
die gasumlage abzuschaffen wenn sich
bestätigt dass diese Zweifel
offensichtlich im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium vorhanden
sind dann gibt es diese Woche die
Gelegenheit die gasumlage sofort zu
stoppen viele offene Fragen viel
Verwirrung heute in Berlin
und darum gehen wir jetzt nach Berlin zu
Schacke unter labenne die was bedeuten
die Entscheidungen die sich jetzt
anbahnen für den politischen Prozess und
den Verbraucher also politisch sieht es
so aus als sei die umstrittene gasumlage
schon vor ihrem eigentlichen Start
Geschichte zwar ist die Bundesregierung
momentan immer noch dabei festzuhalten
daran hat also noch nicht eine
endgültige Absage erteilt an die
gasumlage und es ist auch nicht
wahrscheinlich dass die ampelparteien
der Union zustimmen werden wenn diese
wie angekündigt in dieser Woche noch
einmal den Antrag im Bundestag stellen
möchte auch sofortige Abschaffung der
gasumlage aber die Entwicklungen von
heute zeigen schon dass man es auch in
der Ampel für so missglückt hält diese
Umlage dass sie wahrscheinlich in der
Form in der sie geplant ist nicht kommen
wird allerdings bedeutet das noch keine
Entwarnung für Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher denn noch prüfen
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und
Bundesfinanzministerium und solange die
Prüfungen noch nicht abgeschlossen sind
ist eben auch das endgültige Aus der
gasumlage noch nicht besiegelt und offen
ist dann auch noch die Frage ob es eine
Alternative gibt und was zum Beispiel
mit den Stadtwerken passiert die auch
von der gasumlage profitieren sollte es
sollten also alle die betroffen sind und
betroffen sein könnten noch einmal damit
rechnen dass Kosten auf Sie zukommen
könnten in welcher Form das wird sich
wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Tagen
entscheiden danke nach Berlin
nach dem Rückzug russischer Truppen in
der Ostukraine versuchte Russland neuen
Druck aufzubauen und zwar mit der
Ankündigung Referenten über einen
Beitritt zu Russland abhalten zu wollen
in gleich vier ukrainischen und zum
größten Teil besetzten Regionen schon
zum Wochenende sollen die
Volksbefragungen durchgeführt werden und
mehr dazu jetzt von Volker Duczek
eine Polizeistreife unterwegs sind
wiedereroberten Niemandsland hier im
Süden der Region krakev in istium haben
die ukrainischen Truppen Land
zurückerobert nach sechs Monaten
russischer Besatzung 80% der Gebäude
kaputt die Bevölkerung sehnt den Alltag
jenseits des Krieges herbei auch der
sechsjährige Timo viel
meine Mutter hat gesagt dass ich bald in
den Kindergarten gehen soll Papa hat
mich bei Mama gelassen
moskau will schnell auf die
Rückeroberung von besetzten Gebieten in
donjarz cluansk und anderswo reagieren
im Sommer schon stellten die Behörden
dort russische Pässe aus jetzt sollen
Abstimmungen der Bevölkerung
durchgeführt werden am Ende soll
offenbar ein Ergebnis rauskommen dass
den Wunsch der Menschen nach einem
Anschluss an Russland spiegelt die von
Moskau eingesetzten Verwaltung Chefs
rechtfertigen diese Referenten auch in
krasson
fast jeden Tag erhalte ich Anfragen von
öffentlichen Organisationen und
Einwohnern sobald wie möglich ein
Referendum über den Beitritt zur
Russischen Föderation abzuhalten
per Twitter spricht ukraines
Außenminister Kollege von Schein
Referenden die Ukraine hat das Recht
ihre Territorien zu befreien und wird
sie auch weiter befreien egal was
Russland sagt
indirekt kommentiert Präsident Putin
heute die jüngsten Rückschläge in der
Ukraine er sagt die heimische
Waffenindustrie müsse sich noch weiter
steigern trotz der erzielten Erfolge
besonders hervorheben möchte ich die
Tatsache dass unsere Fahrzeuge den
westlichen Waffen wirksam entgegenwirken
Moskau macht Druck auch gegen die
eigenen Soldaten die Duma beschließt
heute höhere Strafen für die Deserteure
für uns in Moskau ist Christian Sam
Christian angekündigt sind die
Volksbefragungen für Freitag also schon
in drei Tagen warum so schnell was
steckt dahinter
also dass diese umstrittenen Befragungen
kommen dass es jetzt erstmal nicht
überraschend aber das ist jetzt doch so
schnell geht das ist dann doch durchaus
überraschend damit hat man jetzt nicht
gerechnet aber russland will offenbar
Fakten schaffen und im wahrsten Sinne
neue Grenzen ziehen obwohl jetzt schon
klar ist dass das weitgehend
international nicht akzeptiert werden
wird Frankreichs Präsident macron
spricht von einer Provokation auch die
USA sprechen von
scheinenbefragungen die nicht akzeptiert
werden würden und auch Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat sich in New York am Rande der
UN-Generalversammlung geäußert er sagte
wörtlich ich kann das mal kurz zitieren
es sei ganz ganz klar dass diese Schein
Referenten nicht akzeptiert werden
können dass sie nicht gedeckt sind vom
Völkerrecht und von den Verständigungen
die die Weltgemeinschaft gefunden hat
Russland sieht das naturgemäß ganz
anders und das Kalkül ist davon geht man
hier auch aus dass weitere
Kampfhandlungen dann nach einem
Referendum auf russischen Staatsgebiet
fortgeführt würden und da geht die
klaren geht die klare Warnung heute aber
auch schon mal Richtung Ukraine und da
heißt es aus Russland dass man das nicht
akzeptieren werde hier in Moskau geht
man heute Abend noch davon aus dass ich
Vladimir Putin der Präsident noch mal zu
diesen neuen Ankündigungen äußern wird
danke für die Informationen live aus
Moskau Christian semwalders ja der
russische Angriffskrieg aber auch die
Klimakrise und Hungersnöte mit all dem
beschäftigt sich heute die
unvollversammlung in New York zum
Auftakt warnte UN-Generalsekretär gut
vor einem so wörtlich Winter des
weltweiten Unmuts zu dem einenwöchigen
Treffen der Vereinten Nationen sind rund
150 Staats- und Regierungschefs
angereist auch Bundeskanzler Scholz er
wird dort später am Abend noch sprechen
die anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung
in Deutschland ist unzulässig so hat der
Europäische Gerichtshof heute
entschieden das heißt der Staat darf
nicht ohne triftigen Grund
Kommunikationsdaten seiner
bürgerspeichern es geht um das
befristete Speichern von IP-Adressen
also den Adressen die jedem Computer
zugeordnet sind das ist nur zulässig um
schwere Straftaten aufzudecken zum
Beispiel das Hochladen im Netz von
missbrauchsdarstellung streng geschützt
bleiben sensible Handydaten die verraten
wo man sich aufgehalten und mit wem man
kommuniziert hat hier ist eine
Vorratsdatenspeicherung nur möglich wenn
es etwa um eine gefährliche Person wie
ein Mitglied einer kriminellen Bande
geht jetzt muss die Politik also
nachbessern Lars Bohnsack
es ist vielleicht eine der längsten
Debatten in der deutschen Politik welche
Daten wie lange gespeichert werden
dürfen wirklich überraschen kann das
Urteil des EuGH die deutschen
Regierungsparteien nicht dennoch wird
innerhalb der Ampel das Urteil
unterschiedlich interpretiert
das an dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung
wieder besseren Wissens
festgehalten das war aus unserer Sicht
ein großer Fehler die Innenministerin
hätte sich wohl weniger Datenschutz
gewünscht um sexuelle Gewalt gegen
Kinder im Internet besser bekämpfen zu
können will Nancy Faeser dennoch
Spielräume im EuGH-Urteil nutzen die
Speicherung der Daten mit denen wir
Täter identifizieren können ist
unbedingt erforderlich hierfür sind die
IP-Adressen von entscheidender Bedeutung
die nach dem Urteil des heutigen die
heutige Entscheidung des EuGH
ausdrücklich bestätigt gespeichert
werden dürfen das sieht der
Justizminister anders will die Regelung
zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung komplett aus
dem Gesetz streichen und maximal das
sogenannte quick freeze-verfahren
mittragen bei dem nur bei konkretem
Verdacht Daten gesichert würden
nur wenn ein Anlass gegeben ist kann
gespeichert werden und dazu muss ein
Richter oder eine Richterin dazu
entscheiden und wenn dann klar ist dass
diese gesicherten Daten erforderlich
sind um ein Ermittlungsverfahren zum
Erfolg zu führen dann kann mit einer
neuen richterlichen Entscheidung davon
auch Gebrauch gemacht werden so ganz zu
Ende ist der endlos Streit über die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung also immer noch
nicht
in der Linkspartei da brodelt es
gewaltig hoch brisant nennt
Fraktionschefin Mohammed Ali die Lage
und warnt vor einer Spaltung ein
Auslöser ist Sie Sarah Wagenknecht
besonders prominent besonders umstritten
als dümmste Regierung in Europa
bezeichnete sie jüngst die Ampel und
beim Thema Russland Sanktionen da ging
sie noch weiter
das größte Problem ist ihre grandiose
Idee einen beispiellosen
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen unseren
wichtigsten Energielieferanten vom Zaun
zu brechen
ja es folgten danach Empörung und
Prominente Parteiaustritte mehr von
Daniel pontzen
die Stimmung geladen als sich die
Bundestagsfraktion heute Nachmittag zur
Aussprache traf aus Ärger über Sahra
wagenknechts Auftritt im Bundestag
hatten acht Abgeordnete einen Antrag
vorbereitet wonach der Fraktionsvorstand
künftig sicherstellen müsse dass die
Redezeit im Plenum nur für gemeinsam
beschlossene Positionen genutzt werde
hinter verschlossenen Türen ging es dann
heute hoch her das ist erstmal bei uns
keine Neuigkeit das ist jetzt hier auch
kein hippie-stuhlkreis eben gewesen aber
für unsere Verhältnis weil es eine durch
und durch vernünftige kritische Debatte
die wir hier geführt haben es gibt auch
keine Verletzten über den ursprünglichen
Antrag wurde dabei nicht abgestimmt
stattdessen über diesen des
Fraktionsvorstands darin hieß es dass
der Redner die Rednerin grundsätzlich
die Mehrheitsmeinung der Fraktion
vorträgt überredezeiten für Positionen
die davon abweichen entscheidet die
fraktionsversammlung der Antrag wurde
angenommen auch die Wagenknecht Gegner
stimmten zu sagten sie finden sich in
ihm wieder
ja ich bin sehr zufrieden über die
heutige Debatte und auch über den
Beschluss den wir heute ja bei wenigen
Gegenstimmen auch so doch im breiter
Mehrheit getragen haben und es muss
völlig klar sein wer für die Fraktion
spricht muss auch die Position der
Partei vertreten ähnlich zufrieden Klang
Sarah Wagenknecht selbst die der
Fraktionssitzung zugeschaltet war aus
der Maske bei Markus Lanz wo kurz danach
dessen heutige Sendung aufgezeichnet
wurde nein natürlich bin ich noch in der
Linkspartei also wir haben ja in der
Fraktion auch noch mal klargestellt dass
es selbstverständlich die Freiheit des
Mandates gibt der große Knall also blieb
heute aus wie belastbar dieser interne
Burgfrieden ist wird sich in den
nächsten Sitzungswochen zeigen
viele machen sich Sorgen wegen der
steigenden Preise jetzt gibt es starke
Hinweise darauf dass sich die Inflation
noch beschleunigen könnte denn die
Erzeugerpreise also die Preise die
Unternehmen für die Herstellung ihrer
Produkte bezahlen müssen sind im August
um
45,8 Prozent gestiegen der steilste
Anstieg überhaupt im Juli lag das bloß
noch bei gut 37 größter Preistreiber die
Energie Erdgas plus
209,4 Prozent und Strom wurde für die
Firmen um
278,3% teurer das verheißt nichts Gutes
für die Verbraucher und wir fragen nach
bei Frank Bethmann in Frankfurt an der
Börse wie hart wird es denn kommen wenn
ja so viele ist klar das was die
Produzenten jetzt im August
draufgeschlagen haben kommt mit einem
weichen Verzögerung dann auch bei den
Verbrauchern an die Bundesbank rechnet
in ihrem aktuellen Bericht damit dass
die Inflation in den kommenden Monaten
auf 10% oder sogar darüber steigt es ist
davon auszugehen dass fast alles was wir
täglichen Bedarf benötigen nochmals
teurer wird insbesondere die stark
gestiegenen Strom und Gaskosten sind
größtenteils ja noch gar nicht bei den
Haushalten angekommen oft geschieht das
ja erst zum Jahresanfang über die
Nachzahlungen das mit den
Erzeugerpreisen heute sei ein
unfassbarer Preishammer so kommentierte
es vorhin ein Volkswirt der enorme
Preisdruck alarmiert die Notenbanken
gegen eine anziehende Inflation hilft in
vielen Fällen das Anheben der Leitzinsen
Geld wird dadurch teurer die Leute
kaufen weniger die Preise sinken die
schwedische reisbank legt heute vor
erhöht die Zinsen kräftig andere werden
folgen und doch wenn man sich hier so
umhört werden wir noch lange weit über
dieses Jahr hinaus mit der Teuerung zu
kämpfen haben vielen Dank Frank und
liebe Grüße nach Frankfurt
energiepreisdeckel her gasumlage Weg das
forderten erneut viele Menschen bei
Demonstrationen im Osten von Deutschland
in zahlreichen Städten hier Bilder aus
Chemnitz protestierten gestern Abend
Zehntausende gegen die Energiepolitik
der Bundesregierung viele Kundgebungen
angemeldet hatten sowohl linke
Aktivisten als auch Bündnisse die schon
gegen die corona-politik demonstriert
hatten
[Applaus]
die Ständige Impfkommission ist dafür
bei Auffrischimpfungen gegen das
Coronavirus bevorzugt auf die neuen
omicon Entschuldigung Impfstoffe zu
setzen so steht es in einer
Beschlussvorlage der STIKO unverändert
bleibt demnach die zielgruppenempfehlung
für die zweite booster-impfung also
Menschen ab 60 Jahren und Bewohner von
Pflegeheim das Finale STIKO steht aber
noch aus
extremes Wetter in der Karibik dort fegt
Hurrikan Fiona gleich über mehrere
Staaten hinweg mindestens drei Menschen
kamen dabei ums Leben zuerst sorgte der
Sturm in Puerto Rico für Überschwemmung
und Zerstörung dann zog er weiter
Richtung Dominikanische Republik in
jeder zweiten Provinz herrscht
Alarmstufe Rot und Stromausfall
inzwischen ist Fiona auf dem Weg nach
Norden zu den Turks und k-cosinseln
wir sind beim Sport bei Katja und wieder
beginnen wir mit der
Fußballnationalmannschaft so sieht's aus
heute gab es das erste Training des
Teams von Bundestrainer Hansi Flick vor
den beiden nations League spielen gegen
Ungarn und England und gleich ein
kleines schrecksekühnchen denn
jamalmusiala bekam die ganze Härte von
Thomas Müller zu spüren die
Entschuldigung folgte direkt nach dem
faul nach einem Zweikampf mit Müller
zieht sich musiala eine Risswunde am
rechten Schienbein zu und muss
schließlich das Training abbrechen ein
Ausfall gegen Ungarn selber nicht zu
befürchten teilt der DFB mit die
bayern-fraktion hat es eh schon nicht
leicht in diesen Tagen die Krise im Club
holt Kimmich und Co auch im Nationalteam
ein man ärgert sich schon brutal auch
heute schon im Trainingsspiel da war das
auch so ein bisschen sinnbildlich Daten
auch die ein oder andere Chance am Ende
verlierst du dann wieder weil er die
Dinger vorne nicht machst man hat es
schon noch so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf
natürlich die sieben Bayern-Profis beim
DFB müssen die sieglosserie im Verein
möglichst schnell aus den KLE schütteln
doch Rückschläge sind derzeit ein
ständiger Begleiter so tauchte Manuel
Neuer heute nur in Badeschlappen auf
konnte wegen Beschwerden am Zeh nicht
mittrainieren
mindestens neun ratlose und enttäuschte
Gesichter konnte man heute bei der
Ruder-WM in ratzice Tschechien
beobachten denn Deutschlands
eigentliches Paradeboot der Achter mit
Steuermann konnte sich nicht direkt fürs
Finale qualifizieren bis zur 500 Meter
Zwischenzeit sieht das deutsche
ruderflaggschiff noch gut aus scheint
konkurrenzfähig zu sein doch danach
fällt das neu formierte und sehr junge
Team umschlagmann Torben johannesen
deutlich zurück im Ziel bei 2000 Metern
Platz 4 hinter den kanadien die damit
als einzige direkt ins Finale einziehen
am Freitag müssen die Deutschen im
Hoffnungslauf mindestens zweite werden
um das Halbfinale zu erreichen
der Frauen Doppel Vierer hat auf Rang 2
im Hoffnungslauf das Halbfinale erreicht
ebenso wie der doppelführer der Männer
ohne Steuermann und der
leichtgewichts-doppel zweier der Frauen
die ebenfalls zweite in ihren
hoffnungsläufen wurden
immerhin aber ein Herbert Dämpfer für
den Achter Hoffnungslauf was für ein
schönes Wort Dankeschön Katja hier gibt
es gleich das Wetter mit Christa Orban
21 Uhr ist heute journalzeit mariiert
das lomka ordnet die Nachrichten des
Tages ein von uns war es das aus der 19
Uhr heute Redaktion morgen an dieser
Stelle Barbara Halbig danke und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend hoch Stefan breitet sich
jetzt zu uns aus und das bedeutet
dreierlei erstens mehr Sonne am Tag
zweitens mehr Nebel in der Nacht und
drittens die Nächte werden kälter das
ist jetzt heute Nacht auch schon der
Fall 11 Grad gibt es nur noch an der
Ostsee meist gehen die Temperaturen auf
9 bis 4 Grad zurück morgen früh und im
Südosten und der Lüneburger Heide sind
es nur drei bis null Grad und das
bedeutet oft auch Bodenfrost vielleicht
das erste Mal Eiskratzen für viele vor
allem wird das dort der Fall sein wo es
aufklart denn die Schauer fallen jetzt
schnell in sich zusammen etwas Regen bzw
Schnee gibt es aber noch in den
östlichen Alpen dazu schläft der Wind
ein in der Nacht dann kann sich der
Nebel noch einmal weiter ausbreiten und
der muss sich dann morgen früh erst
einmal auflösen dann gibt es aber einen
Tag mit viel Sonne die am häufigsten im
Norden und im Südwesten zu sehen ist
immer mal wieder gibt es dann aber auch
Quellwolken die vor allem über den
Mittelgebirgen Dichter ausfallen können
und eben von der Lausitz und dem
Erzgebirge bis in den Bayerischen Wald
einzelne Schauer bringen dazu gibt es
Temperaturen morgen zwischen 15 und 19
im Südosten sind es 13 14 Grad etwas
milder wird es bis Freitag dazu gibt es
viel Sonne auch wenn immer mal wieder
Wolken mit von der Partie sind ab
Samstag kommt dann von Westen wieder
etwas Regen